welcome to
tensorflow 2.0 tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover today deep learning frameworks
what is tensorflow features of
tensorflow
tensorflow applications how tensorflow
works
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0 tensorflow 2.0
architecture
and then we'll go over a tensorflow demo
where we roll up our sleeves
and dive right into the code so let's
start with
deep learning frameworks to start with
this chart doesn't even do the filled
justice because it's just exploded these
are just some of the major frameworks
out there
there's uh keras which happens to sit on
tensorflow so they're very
integrated there's tensorflow
pie torches out there cafe theano
dl4j and chainer these are just a few of
the deep learning frameworks
we're talking about neural networks if
you're just starting out never seen a
neural network you can go into python in
the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know
but the most robust version out there
the most top
of the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow
and that of course is changing from day
to day and some of these
are better for different purposes so
let's dive into tensorflow
let's see what is tensorflow what is
tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
library released in 2015 by google brain
team for building machine learning
and deep learning models it is based on
python programming language and performs
numerical computations using data flow
graphs to build models
so let's take a look at some of the
features of
tensorflow it works efficiently with
multi-dimensional
arrays if you've ever played with any of
the simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and
make sure your your stuff is set in a
flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here
where you have x and y coordinates where
the picture is and then
each pixel has three or four different
channels
that's a very complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array
it provides scalability of computation
across machines
and large data sets this is so
new right now and you might think that's
a minor thing
but when python is operating on one
computer and it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then on another it
doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow addresses and does a very
good job on it supports fast debugging
and model building
this is why i love tensorflow i can go
in there and i can build a model
with different layers each layer might
have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit
on top of a regular neural network with
reverse propagation
there's a lot of tools in here and a lot
of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard
to visualize the model tensorboard is
pretty uh
recent but it's a really nice tool to
have so you when you're working with
other people or showing your
clients or the shareholders in the
company
you can give them a nice visual model so
they know what's going on what are they
paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
uh clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term
this is the programming side and it's
really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation
fraud detection video detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different
than if you have a set numbers like
you're looking at the stock market
you can use this on the stock market but
if you're doing something where the
numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks and
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are
after all that is what tensor that's
what this is named after so we talk
about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor
a tensor is a vector or a matrix of n
dimensions that represent
all types of data and you can see here
we have the scalar which is just a
single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers might be a number in a direction
you have a simple matrix and then we get
into the tensor
i mentioned how a picture is a very
complicated tensor because it has your x
y coordinates and then each one of those
pixels has
three to four channels for your
different colors and so each image
coming in
would be its own tensor and in
tensorflow tensors are defined by
a unit of dimensionality called as
rank and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
uh so that's a rank one uh matrix would
have rank two
and then as you can see right here as we
get into the full tensor
it has a rank three and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at the basics
of a neural network in reverse
propagation
that is the basics of tensorflow and
then it goes through a lot of different
options and properties that you can
build into your different tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs
it has nodes that represent the
operations in your model
and if you look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs b
c and d and you might have x equals b
plus c
y equals d minus 4 a equals
x times y and then you have an output
and so even though this isn't a neural
network here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because you can actually
one of the
tensors is a neural network with reverse
propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it
and this here is just a basic uh flow of
computations
of the data going across and you can see
we can plug in the numbers uh b equals
four c equals three d equals six
and you get x equals four plus three so
x equals seven
y equals six minus four so y equals two
and finally
a equals seven times two or a equals
fourteen
like i said this is a very simplified
version of how tensorflow works
each one of these layers can get very
complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different
setups up very easily and test them out
so you can test out these different
models to see how they work now
tensorflow has gone through two major
stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed
so many things out there that the 1.0
really needed
so we start talking about tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code
the first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly
and you can see here from tensorflow 1
to tensorflow 2
we have almost double the code to do the
same thing
so if i want to do with tf.session or
tensorflow session
as a session the session run you have
your variables your session run you have
your tables initializer
and then you do your model fit x train y
train and then your validation data your
x value y value and your epics and your
batch size all that goes into the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the
eager so if you see the first part
you're like what the heck is all the
session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into
2.0 it's just nice and clean if you
remember from the beginning i said cross
on our list
up there and cross is the high level
api in tensorflow 2.0 cross is the
official
high level api of tensorflow 2.0 it has
incorporated cross as tf.caras
cross provides a number of model
building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project
and uh we'll hopefully touch base a
little bit more on this sequential
being the most common uh form that is
your
your layers are going from one side to
the other
so everything's going in a sequential
order functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models
and then they come back together and one
of them might be doing classification
the other one might be doing just linear
regression kind of stuff
or neural basic reverse propagation
neural network
and then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into karass
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at
is it in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of
and here we have a little bit more on
the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow 1
asks you to do these different layers
and values if you look at the scope and
the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope
that's not even necessary in tensorf 2.0
so you'd have to do
one before you do do what you see the
code in 2.0
in 2.0 you just create your model it's a
sequential model then you can add all
your layers in
you don't have to pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version
and then we have the last two which is
our api cleanup
and the autograph in the api cleanup
tensorflow 1 you could build models
using tf gans tf
app tf contrib tf flags etc in
tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just
they just cleaned them up because people
weren't using them and they've
simplified them
and that's your tf app your tf flags
your tf logging are all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not
in 2.0 and then we have our tf function
and autograph feature
in the old version tensorflow 1 0 the
python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function
to mark it for the jit compilation for
the python jit
so that tensorflow runs it as a single
graph
autograph feature of tf function helps
to write graph code using natural python
syntax now we just threw in a new word
in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph
is what are all those lines that are
connecting different objects
so if you remember from before where we
had the different
layers going through sequentially each
one of those white lined
arrows would be a graph x that's where
that computation is taken care of and
that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward
you can now put your own function in
there instead of using whatever function
they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although
it could be almost anything out there
depending on what you're doing next
let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic
tools in tensorflow before we roll up
our sleeves and dive into the example
so let's just take a quick look at
tensorflow toolkits in their hierarchy
at the high level we have our object
oriented api
so this is what you're working with you
have your tf cross you have your
estimators
this sits on top of your tf layers tf
losses tf metrics
so you have your reusable libraries for
model building
this is really where tensorflow shines
is between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers
you can your losses your metrics all of
that is so built into tensorflow makes
it really easy to use
and then you can get down to your low
level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction where you do
a linear regression model
and then go to the other where it does a
neural network
and maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it
and then it comes together into another
layer which is
another neural network so you can build
these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around
and most recently we have the tf code
can run on multiple platforms
and so you have your cpu which is
basically like on the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of set up so now you
can export the tf code and it can run on
all kinds of different platforms
for the most diverse setup out there
and moving on from the hierarchy to the
architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with and
80 of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on
uh once you have all that set up you
have your distribution strategy
where are you gonna run it you're gonna
be running it on just your regular cpu
are you gonna be running it uh with the
gpu added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it
or do you have a specialized tpu set up
in there that you paid extra money for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package
you might need to run this on some
really high processors because you're
processing at a server level for
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy
but you're distributing it into a server
where that server might be
analyzing thousands and thousands of
purchases done
every minute and so you need that higher
speed
to give them a to give them a
recommendation
or a suggestion so they can buy more
stuff off your website or maybe you're
looking for data fraud analysis working
with the banks you want to be able to
run this
at a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right
someone's scamming this person and
probably has their credit card so when
we're talking about
all those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is
we were talking about that earlier where
it used to be when you did one of these
models it wouldn't truncate the float
numbers the same and so a model going
from one
you build the model on your machine in
the office
and then you need to distribute it and
so we have our tensorflow serving cloud
on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi
a little breakout board there in fact
they just came out with a new one
that has a built-in there's this little
mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model on to that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product
uh you have the tensorflow js which is
for browser and node server
so you can get that out on the browser
for some simple computations that don't
require a lot of heavy lifting
but you want to distribute to a lot of
end points and now they also have other
language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c
java go c sharp rust r or from whatever
package you're working on
so we kind of have an overview of the
architecture and what's going on behind
the scenes
and in this case what's going on as far
as distributing it let's go ahead and
take a look at
three specific pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and
sessions so very basic things you need
to know and understand when you're
working with the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow
in tensorflow constants are created
using the function constant
in other words they're gonna stay static
the whole time whatever you're working
with the syntax for
constant value d type 9 shape
equals none name constant verify shape
equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant
5.2 name equals x d type is a float
that means that we're never going to
change that 5.2 it's going to be a
constant value
and then we have our variables in
tensorflow variables in tensorflow are
in memory buffers that store tensors and
so we can declare a two by three tensor
populated by ones
you could also do constants this way by
the way you can create a
an array of ones for your constants i'm
not sure why you do that but you know
you might need that for some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice
two by three array that's filled with
ones
and then of course you can go in there
and they're variables so you can change
them it's a tensor so you have full
control over that
and then you of course have uh sessions
in tensorflow
a session in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about
all that information then goes through
all those arrows and whatever
computations they have that take it to
the next node
and you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf
if we do x equals a t f dot constant of
10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0
and then you can do z equals tf.variable
and it's a tf dot add x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer
with tf session as session you can do a
session run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the
10 plus 20 is 30. and we'll be looking
at this a lot
more closely as we actually roll up our
sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through
anaconda and then i'll use specifically
the jupiter notebook on there
and of course this code is going to work
uh whatever platform you choose whether
you're in a notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects
we're going to stick with jupiter
notebook pie charm
whatever it is you're going to use in
here you have your spider
and your qt console for different
programming environments
the thing to note it's kind of hard to
see but i have my main
pi 36 right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3.6
if you have python version 3 7 or 3
8 you're probably going to get some
errors in there might be that they've
already updated it and i don't know it
now you have an older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 36 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up
make sure you go ahead and pip in your
tensorflow or if you're in anaconda you
can do
a conda install tensorflow to make sure
it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom
out depending on what i'm working on
making it really easy to just
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick no errors
yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment
and forgotten to install tensorflow into
that environment
uh or something along those lines so
it's always good to double check
uh and if we're going to double check
that we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that
simply by using the version command in
tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and you know it always confuses me
because sometimes you do tf.version for
one thing you do
tf.underscore version underscore for
another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in
tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i
did tell you the the um we were going to
dig a little deeper into our constants
and you can do an array of constants
and we'll just create this nice array a
equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4361.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that
remember we're in jupiter notebook where
i can just put the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print otherwise you'd write you surround
it in print
and you can see it's a tf tensor it has
the shape the type and the
and the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a two by
two array and if we go ahead and print
the v
out we'll run that and sure enough
there's our tf
variable in here then we can
also let's just go back up here and add
this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
uh we'll have b
tf constant and if we go and print out
v and b i'm going to run that and
this is an interesting thing that always
that happens in here
you'll see right here when i print them
both out what happens is it only prints
the last one unless you use print
commands
so important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print
and surround v with brackets and now we
can see with the two different variables
we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable
and this is just a flat constant so it
comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this labels a tf.tensor and this is
a tf
variable so that's how it's looking in
the back end when you're talking about
the difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v
and with the constant we have a
lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here and
just like any other array in math we can
do like a concatenate or concatenate the
different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated
we just do a tf.concat values
and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes
and if we go ahead and print this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so let's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six
one four five it's concatenated the two
together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one
this means we're doing the columns so if
you had a longer array
like right now we have an array that is
like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two um
axes zero is going to be your first one
and axes one is going to be your second
one
and it translates as columns and rows if
we had a shape
let me just put the word shape here um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes axes one you know
zero one two
that's going to be our columns and if
you can do columns
then we also can do rows and that is
simply just changing the concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy ctrl v
and changes from axes one to axis zero
and if we run that you'll see that now
we concatenate
by row as opposed to column and you have
four three six one seven eight four
seven so it just brings it right down
and turns it into rows versus columns
you can see the difference there your
output this really
you want to look at the output sometimes
just to make sure your eyes are looking
at it correctly
and it's in the format i find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than
understanding what's going on because
conceptually your mind just
just too many dimensions sometimes the
second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array
so tensorflow is utilizing numpy as part
of their format
as far as python is concerned and so you
can treat you can treat this output like
a numpy array because it is just that
it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think
is filling uh one of these with zeros or
ones and so you can see here we just
create a tensor tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we um print out our tensor
again we're in jupiter so i just type
out tensor
and i run this you can see i have a nice
array
of with shape 3 comma 4 of 0s one of the
things i want to highlight here is
integer 32 if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float float64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32.
the reason for this is that we want to
control
how many bits are used in the precision
this is for
exporting it to another platform so what
would happen is i might run it on this
computer where python goes
does the float to indefinite however
long it wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer
and so we need to control whether it's a
tf float 16
in this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float so if i
run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32-bit precision
you'll see zero point
whatever and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a
tensorflow with ones and you might ask
yourself
why would i want zeros and ones and your
first thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job
solving it if you start with a uniform
set of ones or zeros
you're dealing with a lot of bias so be
very careful about starting
a neural network for one of your rows or
something like that with ones and zeros
on the other hand i use this for masking
you can do a lot of work with masking
you can also have
it might be that one tenser row is
masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
um and so in that case you do want to
use the zeros and ones
and there are cases where you do want to
initialize it with all zeros or all ones
and then swap in different numbers as
the
tensor learns so it's another form of
control
but in general you see zeros and ones
you usually are talking about a mask
over another array and just like in
numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four
maybe we wanna swap that to four comma
three
and if we print this out you will see
let me just go and do that
control v let me run that and you'll see
that the
the order of these is now switched
instead of 4 across now we have 3 across
and 4 down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform uh and we'll go ahead and just
take off well we'll go and leave that
i'm going to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71 and then
instead of having this one it rolls down
here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you feel
a lot of times you fill these with
random numbers and so this is
the random dot uniform is one of the
ways to do that
now i just talked a little bit about
this float 32
and all these data types one of the
things that comes up of course
is recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the
projects i've worked on ended up wanting
to do a lot of round off so that it
would take
a dollar amount or a float value and
then have to rent it off to a dollar
amount so we only wanted two decimal
points
in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot
or then convert it to an integer was one
way to round it off
kind of a cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this and we can take this
same tensor and we'll go ahead and
create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor uh and then we're gonna go ahead
and print
our tensor let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo copy and paste works
fine but sometimes be aware that
copy and paste can copy the wrong code
over personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took a float 32
4.6 4.2 and so on
and it just converts it right down to a
integer value
uh sorry integer 32 set up and
uh remember we talked about a little bit
about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did 4
comma 3 on the reshape up here
and we talked about axis 0 axis 1.
one of the things that is important to
be able to do
is to take one of these variables we'll
just take this last one tensor as
integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a
out and we run this you'll see that's
the same array
but we've flipped it so that our columns
and rows are flipped
this is the same as reshaping
so when you transpose you're just doing
a reshape what's nice about this
is if you look at the numbers the
columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row
so you're not maintaining the structure
of your matrix
so when we do a reshape up here they're
similar but they're not quite the same
and you can actually go in here
and there's settings in the reshape that
would allow you to turn it into a
transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so
there are so many times you have to
transpose your digits that this is
important to know that you can just do
that you can flip your rows and columns
rather quickly here
and just like numpy you can also do
multiple your different math functions
we'll look at multiplication and so
we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v four comma
two
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array
but instead we're going to do just a
two by one array and the code for that
is your tf.matte
mole so matrix multiplier
and we have a times v and if we go ahead
and run this up let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this you'll
see that we end up
with 36 by 30. and if it's been a while
since you've seen the matrix math
this is 5 times 4 plus
8 times 2 3 times 4
plus 9 times 2 and that's where we get
the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things is to note is that
just like in numpy you have all of your
different math so we have our tf
math and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
um oh let's do some multiplication
that's always good
we'll stick with our av our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here uh we
have the four
two and the five eight three nine and it
produces
uh 20 32 6 18.
and that's pretty straight forward if
you look at it you have four times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity
which is basically your main values on
the diagonal being ones
and zeros across the other side let's go
ahead and take a look and see what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
ah
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way
very similar to your numpy you can do a
dot shape and it's going to return
a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print we'll do rows
oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this you can see we have
three rows
two columns and then if we go ahead and
create an identity
matrix
the scoops the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d
type is a 32 and then if we go ahead and
just print out
our identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this
as a prediction model and seeing how it
functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup where you can actually see
the full tensorflow in use
for that let's go back and create a
new setup we'll go in here
new python 3 module
there we go bring this out so it takes
up the whole window because i like to do
that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic
understanding of tensorflow as far as
being
a series of numpy arrays you've got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how kara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports
date times warning scipy scipy
is your math so
the back end scientific math warnings
because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions
newer versions and so sometimes when you
get warnings you want to go ahead and
just suppress them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup
and of course date time pandas again
is your data frame think rows and
columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which
of course tensorflow is integrated
heavily with
seaborn for our graphics and the
seaborne
as sns is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as
mpl and then of course we're going to
import our matplot library pi plot as
plt
and right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors
um patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style
you can look this all up there's when
you get into matplot library and to
seaborn
there are so many options in here it's
just kind of nice to make it look pretty
when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color
dim gray line width again this is all
part of our graphics here
in our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns
so we don't want to display more than
50. and then our map plot library is
going to be inline
this is a jupiter notebook thing the
matplot library inline
then warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings
that way when they come up we don't have
to worry about them not really what you
want to do when you're working on
a major project you want to make sure
you know those warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that
into the background so that's a little
back end kind of stuff
then we want to go ahead and do is we
want to go ahead and import
our specific packages that we're going
to be working with which is under cross
now remember cross kind of sits on
tensorflow so when we're importing cross
and the sequential model we are in
effect importing
um tensorflow underneath of it we just
brought in the math probably should have
put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential
now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick
recall on that and so in cross
uh we have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier
and if you remember from here we have a
sequential
where it's going one tensor flow layer
at a time
you go kind of look at think of it as
going from left to right or top to
bottom or whatever direction it's going
in
but it goes in one direction all the
time where functional
can have a very complicated graph of
directions you can have the data split
into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one
where now you're adding your own
subclasses into the
tensor to do external computations
right in the middle of like a huge flow
of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where
cross and tensorflow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers cross
has so many built-in layers you can do
your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go
into cross and we look at their layers
this is across website
you can see as we scroll down for the
cross layers that are built
in we can get down here and we can look
at let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here
we had the relu which is the basic
activation that was listed up here for
layer activations you can change those
and here we have our core layers and our
dense layers you have an input layer a
dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long term short term memory
layer
and of course you can even do your own
custom layers in cross
there's a whole functionality in there
for doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the
convolutional layers this is for
processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is
so popular it's open source and you have
all these tools right at your fingertips
so from cross we're just going to import
a couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer and
then of course from
sk learn our scikit we want to go ahead
and do our min max scalar standard
scalar
for pre editing our data and then
metrics just so we can take a look at
the errors and compute those
let me go ahead and run this and that
just loads it up we're not expecting
anything
from the output and our file coming in
is
going to be air quality.csv and let's go
ahead and take a quick look at that
this is in openoffice it's just a
standard you know
like we can do excel whatever you're
using for your spreadsheet
and you can see here we have a number of
columns
a number of rows it actually goes down
to like 8 000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row is bendung
i'm guessing that's a reference for the
profile if we scroll to the bottom which
i'm not going to do because it takes
forever to get back up
they're all the same the same thing with
the status the status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there
so we have a date and time we have our
o3
co no2 reading so2 no
co2 voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
10 without actually looking through the
data
i mean some of the second guesses like
temperature humidity i'm not sure what
the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality
as far as an area in a region and what's
going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame
df is a nice abbreviation commonly used
for data frames
equals pd.read csv and then our the path
to it just happens to be on my d
drive separated by spaces and so if we
go ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there
overshot but you can see it's the same
data we were just looking at
we're looking at the number we're
looking at the profile which is the
bandung
the date we have a time stamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows
we could easily have done three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas
now i talk about this all the time so i
know i've already said it at least once
or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time
it's come in in two columns we have our
date here
and we have our time and we want to go
ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's
our formula we're building our we're
going to submit
our panda's data frame and the tab name
when we go ahead and do this that's all
of our information that we want to go
ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df shape 0.
so we're going to go through the whole
setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i and
here is our date going in there
and then return the numpy array list tab
d typesdatetime64.
that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead
and do df date time equals combined date
time
and then i always like to print we'll do
df head
just so we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this
uh we now have our setup on here and of
course it's edited on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the format's changed uh so
there's our
we've added in the date time column and
we've brought the date over
and we've taken this format here and
it's an actual
variable with a 0 0 0 on here
well that doesn't look good so we need
to also include the time part of this
and we want to convert it into hourly
data
so let's go ahead and do that to do that
to finish combining our date time let's
go ahead and create a
little script here to combine the time
in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr
forcing this into a date time format and
we can actually spend
hours just going through uh these
conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame how
do you set it up
um so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff
is going to be reformatting these things
resetting them back up
so that it looks right on here and you
know it just takes time to get through
all that but that is usually what the
companies are paying you for that's what
the
big bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data
so there's nothing in there that
exciting and then we want to go ahead
and we'll create a
second data frame here let me just get
rid of the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see what we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time
03 co so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date one two three and so on so
let's group the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want
and in the right sequential order and if
we go back to
um there we go our air quality uh you
can see right here we're looking
at these columns
going across we really don't need since
we're going to create our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want
and that should reflect right here in
the columns we picked
coming across so this is all the same
columns on there that's all we've done
is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at
uh and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe
and this gives us our you know describe
gives us our basic
data analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation uh minimum amount
maximum amount we have our first quarter
second quarter and third quarter
um numbers also in there so you can get
a quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable we're going to look at
a number of things for each variable
and we'll see right here q1 we can
simply do the quantile 0.25 percent
which should match our 25 up here
and we'll be looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're
breaking this down for each uh
different variable in there one of the
things that's kind of
fun to do we're going to look at that in
just a second let me get
put the next piece of code in here um we
gotta clean out some of our
um we're gonna drop a couple things our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles uh so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here
and so this right here as we look at our
different quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here we're going to do a little
bit more with this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows
we're going to go ahead and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
uh column individually and so we'll just
create a q1 q3 min max
min iqr max iqr and calculate the
quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing the math that they
did up here but we're splitting it apart
that's all this is and this happens a
lot because you might want to look at
individual
if this was my own project i would
probably spend days and days
going through what these different
values mean
one of the biggest data science
things we can look at that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3
so we've broken it down we have our q1
5.88 q3 10.37 if we go back
up here here's our 5 8 we've rounded it
off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max
iqr and that's computed let's see where
is it
here we go q1 minus 1.5 times iqr
and the iqr is your q3 minus q1 so
that's the difference between our two
different quarters
and this is all data science
as far as the hard math we're really not
we're actually trying to focus on cross
and tensorflow
you still got to go through all this
stuff i told you 80 percent
of your programming is going through and
understanding
what the heck happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so
when we're looking in that we're going
to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and it usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing
low outliers found minimum value high
outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes
you do this project just to find the
outliers because you want to know
uh crime detection what are we looking
for we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal
and then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness
uh so we have if your max is greater
than iqr
print outlier is found what we want to
do is we want to start cleaning up these
outliers
and so we want to convert we'll do
create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max underscore iqr
min iqr equals mini qr so this is just
saying this is the data we're going to
send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr
and x is less than the min iqr x equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite
you would be cleaning everything else
that's not in that
series so that you can look at just the
outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the
nand hum again we have x max iqr is 100
percent
min iqr is min iqr if x is greater than
max iqr
and x is less than min iqr again we're
going to return
a null value otherwise it's going to
remain the same
value x x equals x and you can see
as we go through the code if i equals
our hum then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column uh then we're
going to go ahead and convert
do the run a map on there and convert
the non
h2m you can see here it's this is just
cleanup
we run we found out that humidity
probably has some weird values in it
we have our outliers that's all this
is and so when we go ahead and finish
this and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06 outliers have been
interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are
these days when you're looking at
something like these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate let the linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
uh same thing with this up here with the
um df2i interpolate
that's what we're doing again this is
all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
uh how do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on
let's take the temp value and we're
going to go ahead and and
use a logarithmic function on the temp
value
and it's interesting because it's like
how do you how do you heck do you even
know to use
logarithmic on the temp value that's
domain
specific we're talking about being an
expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not
what i go look at i don't look at air
care data in fact this is probably the
first air care data set up i've looked
at but the experts come in there and
they come to you and say hey in data
science
this is a exponentially variable
variable on here so we need to go ahead
and do
transform it and use a logarithmic scale
on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who
is a data analysis might be all the way
usually a phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care this needs to be
this is a skew because the data just
goes up exponentially and affects
everything else
and we'll go ahead and take that data
let me just go ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it we
have
our we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the
log temp so we can put them side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df
there's our data frames this is nice
because it just integrates the histogram
right into pandas
love pandas and this is a chart you
would send back to your data analysis
and say hey is this what you wanted this
is how the data is converting on here
as a data science scientist the first
thing i note is we've gone from a 10
20 30 scales a 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
it a little bit based on some kind of a
skew on there
so let's jump into uh we're getting a
little closer to actually doing our
cross on here we'll go ahead and split
our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set uh
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data
make sure it's an integer we don't want
to take a slice as a float value give
you a nice error
and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set
and then we can simply do train comma
test here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
that are going to be for our setup on
here
and if you remember we're specifically
looking at the data set where did we
create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic
value of the temp that's where the data
set came from
so we're looking at just that column
with this train size and the test
with the train and test data set here
and let's go ahead and do uh
convert an array of values into a data
set matrix
we're going to create a little setup in
here we'll create our data set our data
set's going to come in
we're going to do a look back of one so
we're going to look back one piece of
data going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i
and range length of data set look back
-1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data and
take a look at the shape of it
let me go ahead and just put that code
in here so we're going to do a lookbeck
one here's our train x our train y
and it's going to be adding the data on
there and then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape there we
go
and we run this piece of code here we
look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x
1296 comma 1 shape of y train
y test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in and we're only having a
single value at
out we want to predict what the next one
is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's
the um what we're going to train the
data with is yesterday's data yesterday
says hey the humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97
yesterday is it going to go up or is it
going to go down today
of 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there
uh and so our we're looking forward to
the next piece of data which says hey
tomorrow's is going to you know today's
community is this this is what
tomorrow's humidity is going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically x plus 1
or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x
data we're only dealing with the one
column but you
need to have it in a shape that has it
by the columns so you have the two
different numbers
and since we're doing just a single
point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory
layer uh so we're going to add another
reshape on here let me just go down here
and put it into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample
time step features we're only looking at
one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error
in the numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on
uh so we're going to do is we're going
to add one more uh level on here instead
of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more and when they
put the code together in the back you
can see we kept the same shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape
one um and this could have depends again
on how far back in the long short term
memory you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is
and you can see the new shape is now one
1
12 99 1 1 versus the 1299
one and then the other part of the shape
432 1 1
again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test x
and then our y is just a single column
because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for so now
we've done our eighty percent
um you know that's all the the writing
all the code reformatting our data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network uh and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model
and we'll do this sequential model and
if remember sequential means it just
goes in order
that means we have if you have two
layers the layers go from layer one to
layer two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together we're
doing just sequential on here
and then we decided to do the long short
term
memory uh and we have our input shape
which it comes in again this is what all
this switching was we could have easily
made this
one two three or four going back as far
as the
end number on there we just stuck to
going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from um what kind
of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
uh because we're going to do two models
and the next model is going to go ahead
and we're going to do dent so we have
model equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add
a dense model and if you remember from
the very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an
lstm now just about every tensorflow
model uses
dents your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error
or it does reverse propagation to
program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
looks and says here's the error and
sends the error backwards that's what
this
is the long short term memory is a
little different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where
do you find these models what kind of
models do you have available and
so for that let's go to the cross
website
which is the cross dot io if you go
under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for
cross api layers it'll open up and you
can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable
weights all kinds of stuff like there
your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller
arrays or if you're doing convolutional
neural networks the convolution usually
uses a relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft mac
soft plus
all these different choices as far as
how those are set up
and what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and if you scroll down here you'll
see your
core layers and here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing
uh image categorizing so trying to find
objects in a picture that kind of thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually you bring them down into a
single layer
although you can still do like global
max pulling 3d and there is just i mean
this list just goes on and on
there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on long
short term memory is a big one because
this is when we start talking about
text what if someone says the
what comes after the the cat and the hat
a little kid's book there it starts
programming it and so you really want to
know
not only what's going on but it's going
to be something that has a history the
history behind it
tells you what the next one coming up is
now once
we've built all our different you know
we built our model we've added our
different layers we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together
if you do a the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming
linear regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which will use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing
and just like uh any of these uh
different
prediction models if you've been doing
any uh scikit from python
uh you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model uh so what are we doing in
here we're gonna
send in our train x our train y we're
going to decide how many epics we're
going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this i'm
guessing it'd probably be about 200 or
300 probably do just fine
our batch size so how many
different when you process it this is
the math behind it
if you're in data analytics you might
try
know what this number is as a data
scientist where i haven't had the phd
level math
that says this is why you want to use
this particular batch size you kind of
play with this number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math see how
it affects the results
depending on what you're doing and
there's a number of other settings on
here
we did verbose 2. i'd have to actually
look that up to tell you what verbose
means
i think that's actually the default on
there if i remember correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it the big ones are your
epic
and your batch size those are what we're
looking for and so we're going to go
ahead and run this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times through all the data
so if you have a huge data set this is
the point
where you're kind of wondering oh my
gosh is this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera
terabyte of data going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500
iterations uh but yeah a terabyte of
data we're talking something closer to
days week um you know even with a
a 3.5 gigahertz machine
and in eight cores it's still going to
take a long time to go through a full
terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will prail
the process on there more
across multiple processors and multiple
computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere
so we really didn't need to go through a
full 500 epics
you know if you're retraining this stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing
of course if you're going to build a
model we want to go ahead and run a
prediction on
it so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set and our test set or the
we have the train x and the train
y for training it or train predict and
then we have our test
x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
and when we come in here we have you'll
see right here we go ahead and do our
train predict equals
model predict train x and test predict
model predict
test x why would we want to run the
prediction on train x
well it's not a hundred percent on its
prediction we know it has a certain
amount of error
and we want to compare the error we have
on what we programmed it with
with the error we get when we run it on
new data that's never seen the model has
never seen before
and one of the things we can do we go
ahead and invert the predictions
this helps us level it off a little bit
more um
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
um exponential m1 the train predict
and then train y equals the exponential
m1
for train y and then we do the again
that with train test
predict and test y
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches
and then we want to go ahead and
calculate the root mean square error
so we have our train score uh which is
your math square root times the mean
square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
um this is just
feeding the data through so we can
compare it and the same thing with the
test
and let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see we're doing
but the answer really helps to zoom in
so we have a
train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error and we
have a test score of 3.16 of the root
mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is
better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong
at that point you got to go back and
figure out what you did wrong
uh because you should never have a
better result on your test data than you
do when you're training data
and that's why we put them both through
that's why we look at the error for both
the training and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model
it's the test score that you're showing
people this is what it did on my test
data that the model had never seen
before
this is how good my model is and a lot
of times you actually want to put
together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.1
i'd have to go back and we're up here
if you remember we did the square means
error this is standard deviation that's
why these numbers are different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here
so we can go ahead and go with that uh
and along with
putting a formal print out of there we
want to go ahead and plot what's going
on
and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on
when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise
and so at this point we really want to
put it in a graph so we have something
to display
and with displaying you remember that
we're looking at uh the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting
we have our train predict plot np
empty like data set train predict plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the data groups as we like them and then
putting the data in there is what's
going on here
uh so we have our train predict plot uh
which is going to be our look back
our length plus look back
we're just is going to equal train uh
train predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it so now we have our nice
train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops
looks like i put it in here double no
it's just a
yeah they put it in here double didn't
mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because
this is the test predict so we have our
training prediction
we're doing the shift on here and then
the test predict
we're going to look at that same thing
we're just creating those two
data sets uh test predict plot
length prediction set up on there and
then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions
so we have a time axis always nice to
have your time set on there
set that to the time array time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom
and then we have a lot of stuff going on
here as far as setting up
our figure let's go ahead and run that
and then we'll break it down
we have on here our main plot we have
two different plots going on here the
ispu going up and the data and the ispu
here
with all these different settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here
so we're doing a figure plt or
plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there and so we take
and if you go through the code piece by
piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly
we're going to label it the original
data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot
that's what we just created we're going
to make that orange
and we'll label it train prediction test
prediction plot we're going to make that
red and label it test prediction
and so forth set our ticks up this
actually just put ticks
time axes gets its ticks the little
little marks they're going along the
axes that kind of thing
and let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
um here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction you can
see that it trains pretty close to what
the data is up there
i would also probably put a like a
little
little time stamp and do just right
before and right after
where we go from uh train to test
prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this
is is just the test prediction on the
right
uh and it's you know there's you'll see
with the original data set
there's a lot of peaks were missing and
a lot of lows were missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty
does pretty good it's pretty right on
you can get a good idea what to expect
for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error
that's the kind of thing i put out on a
daily basis maybe we predict the cells
are going to be this or maybe weekly
so you kind of get a nice you kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big
takeaway from this is that we're working
with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows and that is to build
this
sequential model and we're only putting
in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too hate-wire on that and
that you kind of learn as you go again
it's domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in
and say this is what we want to try but
i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
uh working with somebody and they're
like oh my gosh if i only did a
tangent h instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well as a data science i can
run it through the model in you know
five minutes instead of spending two
weeks doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side
and a data analytics is going to look
for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of
tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently
and of course uh with any data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders
again we want to take and reduce
the information down to something people
can look at and say oh
that's what's going on they can see
stuff what's going on as far as the
dates and the change in the ispu
so that's going to wrap up the module on
tensorflow
thank you for joining us today simply
learn for more information please visit
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here